How are you? Okay, training on a midi-doro-exampti, sorry, so we're going to go over this
adhesive because there's a lot to learn with neurology and there's doctors that are
tire-practors that spend three full weekends when I trained the other doctor that I had
here centered a three full weekends to really get trained in the pathways. Now I'm not
expecting anybody to learn all the pathways, but some of the ideas are important. So you're
dealing with any neuropathy, whether it's a neuropathy, so neuropathy means neuropathy,
neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy
neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy,
neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy, neuropathy,
is like numbness, tiglead, or you know, loss of feeling, or pain, and nerve. When you talk about
peripheral neuropathy, you're really talking about numbness, tiglead, loss of any feeling,
vibrational sense in the periphery, which is your hands and your feet. So the periphery of your body,
obviously, it's the last blood flow, and it gets the worst blood flow, right? It's a farthest from
your heart. So there could be diseases like the most common is diabetes that they get peripheral
neuropathy. The number one cause of death I think of people over 70 is falling because they can't
feel their feet where they are in space anymore. So they think that they're foot is above the curve
and they catch their toe on the curve and they trip in the fall. So peripheral neuropathy is
especially with their ag population becoming a bigger and bigger deal. So to be able to handle that
and be able to help those people is important. As far as from an oncology cancer perspective,
peripheral neuropathy is really common when you are exposed to a toxin like chemotherapy that
damages your nerves. So how can you help these people with peripheral neuropathy? So you can
have damaged nerves from too much excess sugar. You can have damaged nerves from a poison like
chemotherapy. You can have also damaged nerves from an injury, you know, fractured their ankle,
really bad, something like that. So there's two main trunks of nerve fibers. There's nerves that go
from your brain to a site and there's nerves that go from a site to your brain and those are called
efferid and efferid nerves. So your efferid nerves go from your brain to a receptor or to a tissue
to an organ to a cell and your efferid nerves go typically from a receptor to the brain. So those are
the ones that we're really going to be talking about as those efferid nerves, the ones that go from
a receptor to the brain. So I tell people all the time like when you smash your toe where does it
hurt? Well it hurts them by toe. When you have it really your toe has receptors in the skin at the
joint and you know the muscle and when you stimulate those receptors it fired in impulse back up to
the brain to the opposite side of the parietal lobe because across over the core goes up to the
parietal lobe. You're actually feeling the pain in your opposite parietal lobe. That's why people with
phantom leg syndrome like they don't have a leg anymore. They got amputated in the war but they swear
their foot is itchy like crazy and it's driving them literally insane and the treatment used to be
well will epitone higher, well epitone higher, well epitone higher. Tell you realize duh they're not
feeling it in their foot because it doesn't exist. They thought it was a psychosis or something but it's
actually you still have the neural map of that foot in the brain. So you have a specific neural map
of every somatic piece of your body in the brain. That's called your homunculus if you wanted to know.
So that homunculus in the brain is this odd shaped neural map. If you took out your parietal lobes here
and you looked at them you have this neural map of where your foot is, where your D is. It's in this
part of the brain and even though I don't have a D or foot anymore that that's gone. I could still have
some sort of thing stimulating that part of the brain and I feel it in my foot even though the foot
isn't even there anymore. Do you understand? So you have to look at the neurology of an issue.
So what a person has a loss of numbness. They have numbness particularly the loss of sensation of any kind
that's a peripheral neuropathy or neuropathy. Then you start asking the question why. So if they have
a sensory issue, I can't feel my foot. I have numbness or I have this constant tickling. You go
which a ferret nerve is damaged. Where is the damage? So I said there's a ferret and a ferret.
A ferret is from the brain to the tissue. A ferret is from the tissue, typically a receptor
to the brain. So it's the a ferret nerves that we're looking at. There's two major
trunks of a ferret nerves. It's based upon what they do and they're labeled based on their size.
There's the large diameter a ferrets in the small diameter a ferrets. The large diameter a ferrets
are almost always the first ones to die off in diabetes or in chemotherapy any sorts of chemical
damage to the nerves. The large diameter a ferrets I think because they're larger will die first.
And then the person will have small diameter a ferret fiery and then those will die and then
none of them will work and that's the person who doesn't feel their toes or feet at all and those
are the person that are really at danger. When you start healing them, it is the small diameter
ferrets that come back first and then the large diameter a ferrets. So knowing what those do and
knowing that pathway is really important because that's how we tested as well. So the large diameter
a ferrets carry light touch, carry vibration and carry hot and cold. A couple of other things,
but those are the main things. The small diameter a ferrets carry pain. So really important to know.
I have pain in my feet all the time. Well that means probably the large diameter a ferrets are
dying off and you're really feeling the small diameter for its fire. So follow me so far. So the
large diameter a ferrets carry light touch, vibrational sets and hot and cold. They fire back just
the neurology of them. So if it's this large diameter a ferrets in this foot, if fire is back
to your spinal cord, this is your right side of the right side and it sends these auxiliary fibers out
in this spinal cord first, do not get there yet, in this spinal cord it sends these auxiliary fires out
that inhabit the small diameter a ferrets. Think about that how cool that is. So your large diameter
a ferrets that are light touch vibration and hot and cold inhibit pain. They inhibit the small
diameter a ferrets fibers so that you put out a pair of socks, okay, it's awarding. That's light touch,
right. I don't want to have my socks is really, right? Because you got that constant irritation.
It's actually inhibiting pain so you don't even feel your socks after a while. It's an inhibiting
pain. So your small diameter a ferrets or your large diameter a ferrets inhibit the small diameter
a ferrets. So that's abbreviate those. The LDAs inhibit the SDAs. They inhibit pain. So when a person
starts going out getting pained by feet, I get a lot of pained by feet. You know their large diameter
a ferrets are dying off. You just know it already and then you want to test them. So there's the way to
test for the LDAs. It's really easy. I'll show you, okay? So the LDAs inhibit the SDAs. They
inhibit pain. So the first thing that happens with the person with peripheral neuropathy is they start
to get all these weird sensations. Tickly numbness and pain. So they feel like somebody's pricking them
with with pins. They feel like they got all these pins and needles all over their legs, okay?
So and that's what they feel like and then they just get pained and then eventually they get
numbness. And that's really bad, okay? So how do we test for the LDAs? We'll talk about how we treat it
because it's actually quite simple with the PEMF. So you just basically treat it with the PEMF
and laser. All you do is stimulate those nerves to come back. You could also use the vibration
as well. So we use biplates. Or some could stay out of the biplates. That's very good for
stimulating their LDAs. So let's have the patient lay down on their back. So the test, the
neurological test for LDAs will scroll over one right now is this one. And this one's really effective,
especially if they have a guest with them, okay? So I say you have five toes at each side. So
pretend these are your toes. I am going to touch two toes, two toes at the same time.
If you're going to tell me how many toes are between the two I touch. So here'd be two, here'd be one,
here'd be zero, here'd be zero, here'd be zero, here'd be one, here'd be one. This is exactly how I
explain it to them because I find the same. I'm going to touch two toes, tell me how many toes are
between the two I touch. They're like, okay, 90% of the time, they're not even listening to you,
okay? They're not even listening. They're just like, oh god, they're not going to leave. What is?
They're going to come up there. There are people I think are going to want all sorts of things. So
you've got to go, look here, I'm going to touch two toes. How many toes? If these are your toes,
how many are between the two I touch? Zero. And sometimes you have to repeat this back to them,
and I don't want to sound like people are dumb, but they're just, they're not registered,
they're up, they keep, they're nervous, they're scared, whatever. So how many are here? Okay,
and then this message, when I touch down here, it sends a signal back to your cord, 270 miles an
hour. So if you go, um, you fail. You have to think about it, it's a fail. Even if you get it right,
if you took you a second or two, it's a fail. So I'm going to touch two toes, how many toes are between
the two I touch? Then this is how I do it. Zero, good. So she got all right except one, right?
That's really good. That's really good. Most people will get most from wrong. You know,
when you got a person with their rapidly, they're like, literally, they'll be like, how many between
the two I touch and they'll go, do you touch it? I'm not getting it. They can't you feel it. So,
all right, then they'll go three, four. You're just guessing, aren't you? You know, there's no way
there could be four between the two I touch. That's what you got to say. So you know, they'll just get
a lot wrong and usually they just fall so go, oh my gosh. Okay, they can't, they just, they can't tell
that I'm even touching two toes, lots of times. They're touching any toes sometimes. So you'll get that
wrong, but you don't want to go. Okay, it's just light touch. You're just touching. It's like this
and let it go. That's not sustained touch. Now, that is another test. If they got them all wrong, you go,
okay, I wanted to see how about sustained touch? How many are between you two? No. How many? No.
It's a little easier, so you're making it a little bit easier for them, but you're not trying to make it
easier. You're trying to really try them here. That was difficult, though, for me to gauge. It was. Could
you imagine if you had neuropathy? Yeah, because you're not looking at it. And then you go to the other side
and you do the same thing. You want to do about six or seven tests, right? And if you mess up like
you, your hand jiggles and oh, do the whole thing. Do it again. Just say, do it again. And you do that
and you go, wow, you got half of these wrong. And you got most of these wrong. So if you know,
your large doctor cutter is going to should tell you to explain that about your large diameter efforts,
but that's not good. Yeah. Okay, so I could teach you guys to do the whole mirror exam and come in,
I could come in and get a oversee it or go over the exam findings, but they'll be even with
their regular patients. But that's just one aspect of that that you can tell already. We know
their, their LDAs are whacked years old. But if you got all those wrong or half of them wrong,
we got some problems so that we need to stimulate your LDAs. And I would be willing to bet that if
you tested anybody here that's over 40, they got, they're not real good at this. Because this is
literally everybody over 50 is starting to have issues with this. Okay, so it's because of,
you know, our diets, you know, just to bad diet causes issues and damages the nerves.
So we talked about this in terms of, of if your LDs are bad that they are repairable. Yes.
And that's a reputable condition. But could it ever get to a point where your, you know,
LDAs and SDAs are damaged to a point of no return? It's not possible. Not really. No. Not really.
You know, you have to deal with some people that say if they have chemotoxicity,
then you have to deal with getting rid of that too. Do you know what I'm saying? And if you have to
deal with somebody who's got, you know, uncontrolled diabetes, you know, you can have them every day
of the week doing laser and PEMF. And they probably see some improvement. But if they have uncontrolled
and they're not willing to change your diet deal or even take their diabetes meds, then you're
probably going to be quite the endless panel. But we have people that have really, really bad
peripheral neuropathy. I know other doctors that have bad people with, you know, always get a
better. So I have a friend that he offers two free treatments. He does the whole thing on everybody
for the two treatments. If you don't feel a teeny little bit better, and you don't want to do this,
then they're just free. But if you feel any better, then this is the cost of our program. But he gets
most people to sell them because they'll feel already better after doing it. He does, I think, he does,
he does like four therapies on them. So he's hitting them pretty hard. So the PEMF would be the
primary one. So the PEMF is one. The laser is another, the sound therapy for us would be another one,
big time. And I know a lot of the other doctors do the rebuilder and they do another machine that's
called Haka Man, that's similar to our art. But so they have a lot of therapy assistants
doing therapies of these people. So they sign up for like a number of visit package with a number of
visits. Not per therapy, but number of visits. So that's how they do it. That makes sense. So that
be one neurological test. There's multiple other tests that I could teach you, but that's the start.
It's a great start. So you can practice that on everybody. So that's the large diameter
appearance. You need to learn how to say those words. And the key component to that is that when you
large diameter efforts go, your pain not only don't hear is going to ramp up, your pain everywhere
is going to ramp up. So when people have an increased pain issue, it is, you know, part of it is because
of a loss of your large diameter, after it's worldly testing the ones in the toes here,
with the receptors in the toes, to test this whole path here. But you could do the same thing with
the hands, the exact same thing. Close your eyes. How many fingers do I, between the two I touch?
You do the same test. So you just have to hold your hands out and you do the exact same thing with
their hands. And that's the proper way to do it because then you're testing the upper and the lower
extremity. Even if they don't have lower extremity issues. For lying patients, this is really
this is really important. For cancer patients, like who cares if they have support for their
upper knee, they're going to die of cancer, we got to get on that right away. But for lying patients,
one of their biggest issues is pain. So that's why if you can stimulate the LDAs to heal, you're going
to decrease their overall body pain. Period. Because that's your biggest inhibition of pain.
There's your own large diameter effort pathways. So if you could heal the LDAs, you could really
call the person's pain down. That makes sense? Give yourself the practice. All right.